[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SACHIT EGAN: So
today, generally,
we're going to talk a
little bit about two topics,
one of them being identity--
which we're going to talk about
in a few moments--
and also around building a
championship team culture.
And Rick and
Jennifer, both of you
have been part of great
teams, great organizations.
And so I just wanted to begin by
asking, what goes into building
a great culture at work?
RICK WELTS: Go ahead, Jennifer.
JENNIFER AZZI: Me start?
OK.
I think it starts
with leadership.
I think it starts with
having authentic leadership.
And I think that makes
a big difference.
And I think, if you
are a good leader,
you have to identify the
values of your group.
And then once you
do that, I think
you have to really
live by those values.
And obviously, you have to set
a vision, and goals, and so on.
But I think you have to
have authentic leadership,
and I think you have to have
everyone's values aligned
and going towards the
same goal, same place.
SACHIT EGAN: Very good.
RICK WELTS: Sounds very simple.
JENNIFER AZZI: OK.
Yeah.
RICK WELTS: Really hard to do.
JENNIFER AZZI: Exactly.
RICK WELTS: And I
think, my experiences
in the organizations I've
been in, most of the time,
I've gotten to an
organization when
it was a little bit broken.
I seem to be attracted to
that kind of a situation.
Something wrong with me.
But I also think it
is a real opportunity
in the lifecycle of a company
to make significant change.
Rather than go into
an organization that
has tremendous success and
trying to make it incrementally
10% better, it's a lot
more interesting for me
to go to an organization that
is really not functioning
and try to make 100%
change in the way people
show up at work every day.
And we can talk a lot a
lot about what that means.
SACHIT EGAN: Yeah, for sure.
And I think you both can speak
to that type of experience.
Obviously, you with
the Suns and then the
Warriors, and you with
a very stagnant USF team
that you took over.
Can you share any
examples of early actions
you tried to take to
change the culture?
JENNIFER AZZI:
Well, like Rick, I
think I'm drawn to
difficult situations.
And I think for me, taking over
the program at USF, ignorance
was bliss because I'd never been
in a head coaching role before,
and actually had
never coached before.
So that was kind of a good
thing in the beginning.
And I thought I could
change the culture,
and I thought I could change
the mindset of what was already
there.
And it was very
difficult. There's
a reason that teams win,
and there's a reason
that teams lose.
And oftentimes, it's
right between your ears.
It's your thought process.
It's the way you do things.
And the program at USF was
not only in the bottom 10%,
it was probably the
bottom 5% in the country.
So I thought we could
make change quicker--
it's not like a pro
organization where
you can change your personnel.
You really have to paint
a picture every day
of what your values
are, what the culture's
going to look like.
But it's really,
really difficult
to change what is there without
making significant changes.
And for us, that took six years
before we won a championship.
SACHIT EGAN: Wow.
What about you with the
Suns and with the Warriors?
RICK WELTS: Very different.
Suns were historically a
very successful franchise
but had fallen on hard
times competitively
and financially at
the time I got there.
So people there had
experienced success,
and experienced
a lot of success,
so it was just a recalibration
to get back to where we were.
Warriors, completely different.
This is-- for those of you
who are fans, the way the NBA
playoffs work, more than
half the teams, 16 out of 30
actually make the playoffs.
The Warriors had not made the
playoffs 16 out of 17 years.
And I actually don't think you
could write that business plan
and execute it.
Just by chance, you would
end up in the playoffs
more often than that.
So there was a culture
where everybody
came to work every
day expecting to lose.
That's just the way it was.
It was in the business office,
it was in the locker room.
And you know what?
It seemed to go just fine.
Like every year,
everybody got a raise,
everybody got a long
summer, because you
didn't have long playoffs.
You came back the next year,
you did it all over again.
So that one was a complete
reset about getting people
who wanted to come
along for the ride
to believe what we were going
to be, not what we had been.
And it was a really
interesting process
for the first year of the
people who clearly could
get their heads around
that, and want to come along
for the ride, and the people
who really didn't believe
we were going to
accomplish what I said
we were going to accomplish.
SACHIT EGAN: I see.
This is really interesting.
You mentioned that
winning, losing,
it's between in
between the ears.
You say that it's a mentality,
an expectation to lose.
We were talking before
this chat that we
had Baron Davis at a Talks at
Google event maybe a month ago,
and--
RICK WELTS: I'm laughing.
That must have
been entertaining.
SACHIT EGAN: Right.
It was.
Go watch the video on
YouTube if you haven't.
But he described the same thing.
He talked about how he shows
up, he wasn't initially excited.
He said he didn't even want
to come to the Warriors.
And he shows up, and he felt
that, organizationally, people
felt like losing.
And his approach he
talked about on stage was,
let me get to know every
level of the organization.
Let me get to know the trainers,
the ball boys, the doctors.
Obviously, the team,
the front office.
Let me try to figure
out what they're about,
and try to influence
them individually.
Does that approach
resonate with you both,
or have you found other tips
or tricks that have helped?
JENNIFER AZZI: Absolutely.
I think any championship
team I've been on,
whether it's as a coach,
or a player, or somewhere
in between, everyone
felt a part of it,
from the person that sweeps
the floor to the leader
of the entire organization.
And everyone's energy has to
be going the same direction.
And I can really relate
to what Rick said too
about the culture
of the Warriors,
because it was the same at USF.
I think people had
gotten really complacent.
And I think, oftentimes,
human nature is
people want to be comfortable.
So a big thing that we used
to talk about with our team
is, get comfortable with
being uncomfortable,
because it's going to be hard.
And if you want to succeed,
and you want to win, it's hard.
We had class conflict,
so I got tired of it.
We practiced at
6:00 in the morning.
And once the team
got used to it,
and then they felt like
great high achievers,
you get through that
practice, and you've
achieved something greater
than you have in years.
But it's a lot of work.
SACHIT EGAN: Yeah,
I understand that.
RICK WELTS: I think
one thing that you
have to commit to the people
who work with you is that you're
going to judge each person
by their own abilities
and their own talents.
So we had, again,
a lot of people
who had not been
successful, or been
buried in the organization.
And the promise
was, look, you're
going to excel in this
organization based
on what you do and
the talent that you
bring to work every day.
And we now, through
that process,
ended up with two or three,
today, of the senior leaders
in the organization
who have been there
for 17 years, because
they were kind of buried
in the organization, and hadn't
really been given a voice,
or been given the
opportunity to show.
And to me, that was important
to have some of those success
stories to go along
with all those people
who weren't going to stick
around who we then could go out
and recruit the
best and brightest
in those particular disciplines.
And the combination
of that, I think,
gave the senior
team, especially,
some organizational
credibility, because people all
knew they're there
for a good reason.
And I think that's been
a big part of how we've
been able to navigate this.
SACHIT EGAN: Interesting.
So one of the things that
I was going to ask about
is, as a casual fan,
a casual observer,
when we talk about team culture,
it often is really talking
about the on-court product.
What's going to happen
to the Warriors culture
if we add DeMarcus Cousins?
Things like that are
what we talk about.
And both of you
are talking so much
about the whole organization.
And I know Rick
has talked about--
you started your basketball
career at 16 years old
as a ball boy for
the Seattle Sonics,
and so you saw how
the doctors interact
with the players, the staff--
it's a full-- the
organization's like a living,
breathing entity.
And I remember you've said it
hasn't changed much since then
to now.
Can you tell us about that?
RICK WELTS: Well, I had
an amazing advantage
the people who sit in my
seat don't get to have.
So I'm a fly on the wall as
a 16-year-old kid in an NBA
locker room getting to
see exactly what you said,
the interaction between players,
between players and coaches.
Nobody's paying any
attention to me.
I can just soak all this in.
The media, training staff,
ownership, reporters.
It was a wonderful crash
course that I still, I
think, call on today.
And it hasn't changed that much.
The dynamics in sports
of what those roles are,
and how they intersect.
The one that has changed
probably more than any
is the media, because when we
were entertaining the media
after a game, then,
there were two or three
reporters who were
print reporters who
were covering the team.
And now, today, at
a Warriors practice,
we probably have
30 or 40 reporters
representing all kinds
of media outlets that--
players, frankly,
used to be able to get
away with a lot more.
And reporters used to
protect players in ways,
because they had a different
kind of relationship
than they do now.
I can tell you,
professional athletes
today are under more scrutiny
than any profession, period,
in terms of their
personal behavior
and how they conduct themselves.
It's really hard, because
you are always on.
I mean, TMZ is this
far away, right?
And it's actually,
I think, quite
remarkable to see the way
that locker room has evolved
as it relates to the media.
SACHIT EGAN: Very cool.
And Jennifer, for you, a lot of
us in the audience-- people who
work in tech-- it's
pretty in vogue right
now to jump jobs a lot,
whether it's internally
move around within
the Silicon Valley,
externally to other companies.
And I was thinking
about your career.
Professionally with a
few different teams,
playing for the
Olympics, coaching
in the collegiate ranks,
winning a championship
as a college athlete.
I guess I wonder, how did
your perception of what
makes a good team culture
or a good team leader
evolve from being a player
to then being a coach?
JENNIFER AZZI: Wow.
That's a tough one.
I think just being around
people that were successful,
and watching what
they did and how
they did it, is--
and then I also,
before I started
coaching, I kept
a little notebook of the
things I liked and didn't
like about certain coaches
so that when I coached,
I wouldn't do the
things that I thought
were maybe not appropriate,
or not motivating,
or that kind of thing.
So I just think I've always
looked around me, whether it's
in the sports world
or not, but at people
that are good at their
jobs, and good leaders,
and really tried
to learn from that.
But I think team
culture is pretty
consistent across the board.
If you have people that care,
and that are very engaged,
and all are moving in
the same direction,
and, I think, who
are-- and I know
we're going to get
to talk about this,
but who are really
authentically themselves,
when you can bring your whole
self to what you do and you
don't feel split, I
think that also makes
a very successful situation.
SACHIT EGAN: Very cool.
That's a good
transition, actually.
JENNIFER AZZI: Thank you.
SACHIT EGAN: We appreciate that.
So we talked a
bit about culture,
and identity is another
thing that's important.
And we were chatting
before about how
a core tenet of
Google's culture is
that we should all
feel comfortable
bringing our whole
selves to work.
And so what does
identity mean to you,
and has that changed for you
over your life and career?
RICK WELTS: Well, it's certainly
changed for both of us.
So it wasn't until 2011 in
this little front-page story
on "The New York Times," I came
out as a gay man in sports.
And at the time, the
highest-ranking person
in my career, or my field,
that had taken that step.
And up until that point, I
was a really happy person.
I had a really
successful career.
But especially in men's
professional sports,
there was this fear in
me that somehow bringing
my authentic self to
work could potentially
be damaging to the career
that I wanted to have.
And it took me a long
time to get to the point
where I felt I was at a place
where it was important to me
to take that step.
And I don't regret
how long it took me.
It was my story.
It's my process.
It happened at the right time.
It's wonderful now to have
a different relationship
with some of my co-workers.
I had purposely set
up walls around what
people felt comfortable
approaching me about.
No one ever asked me if I
was gay in my entire career.
But when I came in
after the weekend,
I would purposely not ask Jen
what she did that weekend,
because I didn't want her to ask
me who I was hanging out with,
or what I was doing.
So people figure it out, and
are respectful about that,
but it's a sacrifice.
It's a sacrifice to somebody
who's in that position.
I wish I'd had
better relationships
with a lot of those people at
different level than I had.
I do have those now,
which is awesome.
And I think I'm
probably better at what
I do at work because
of that now today,
and I think I'm
probably a better
leader because of that today.
But that's a journey.
But yes, did it change?
It changed pretty significantly.
JENNIFER AZZI: Yeah.
RICK WELTS: For you too.
JENNIFER AZZI: Well, yeah.
And I thought everyone knew.
It didn't feel like I had to
make some big announcement,
like I'm gay, I have a--
at that time-- a
partner, now wife.
And it didn't change until
I was actually introducing
Rick at the ADL Awards.
And I remember going for a run
in the morning with my wife
Blair.
And I said, OK, I'm going to
introduce Rick this evening,
but I don't know how
I can do him justice.
First of all, I don't
know why I'm doing it,
but I don't know how
I can do him justice.
I can't just read his bio.
I've got to do something.
And she's like, oh,
you'll be great.
Whatever you want
to say is fine.
So then I get on stage,
and I just said, thank you,
because his example for me
has helped me in so many ways,
but absolutely helped
me in a leadership role.
And I thought being open with
my team, or my players at USF
would actually hurt me as well.
I thought, if you're
the gay coach,
well, then you're not
going to get any recruits,
and it's going to
change everything.
And it actually did
just the opposite.
I ended up becoming a lot
closer with my players.
And I think they respected
me that much more.
They definitely respected
me for my knowledge.
But I didn't realize that they
didn't feel like they knew me.
I thought they knew me because
I'm the same person every day.
I walk in, I'm positive, I'm me.
I'm doing my job.
But when you can go on a
deeper level with people,
I think you can have so
much more of an impact.
And what I realized is there
were so many people around me
that I either knew or
didn't know that had
the same struggle going on.
And so after introducing
Rick and having this whole
coming out thing, it
made a big difference.
And my wife and I got
emails, and calls,
and things from
people that were gay,
straight, anything, emailing
us saying, just thank you.
Thank you for being
authentic, and being
a good example for us.
SACHIT EGAN: Wow.
So you both have talked
about having a full career,
a really successful,
happy career
prior to making that choice.
And so I do want to ask--
I know Rick's story a little
bit in that you'd lost a parent
and a lot was going on in your
life when you were in Phoenix.
What went into, for both of you,
making that choice, I guess?
Yeah.
JENNIFER AZZI:
Well, mine was easy.
It was Rick's fault. So he--
if he hadn't asked me to do
that, I don't know if I--
RICK WELTS: She sold the show.
JENNIFER AZZI: Yeah, exactly.
RICK WELTS: [INAUDIBLE]
fill this up.
JENNIFER AZZI: No, I think
it was just the right moment.
Like Rick, I too
don't regret anything.
It was the right time for me.
It was the right moment for
me, that just kind of hit me.
And I think hopefully
helps people, and has
some type of a positive impact,
but I don't know about you.
RICK WELTS: Well,
I had been thinking
about this for a while.
And I would have a bad breakup.
And part of it was
because I couldn't include
the person who was most
important in my life
into my professional life.
And that made a
big impact on me.
My dad had passed
away and my mother
had been diagnosed
with lung cancer,
so I had really decided
it was now or never.
And I didn't have any idea
how to put it in perspective.
So I actually invited
a friend of mine.
His name's Dan Klores.
I don't know if you're
watching right now.
The "Basketball: A Love
Story," the series on ESPN.
He actually produced
"Basketball: A Love Story."
But in his prior life, was kind
of a media guru of New York.
And I invited him to
go to dinner one night
and just said, Dan,
I don't even know
how to put this in perspective.
I need your view of this.
I'm thinking of doing this.
And I can either just talk
to the people I work with,
and the people I've
worked with in my life,
and that'll be great, and we
can take care of it that way.
But maybe there's something
gnawing at me that says,
maybe there's something
better that can
be accomplished by doing that.
And he--
[CHUCKLES]
It's going to be a great
scene in the movie.
He looked across the
dinner table at me,
and he just said, Ricky--
he's got this funny
voice, calls me Ricky.
Ricky, if you're willing to
do this, I want to help you.
And I think it's page
A1, "New York Times."
And that was kind of
my oh, shit moment.
Like, whoa.
Serious.
And so we went on a journey.
He connected me with a
Pulitzer Prize-winning reporter
from "The New York
Times," and "The Times"
wanted to do the story, and
make it a front-page story.
And because I'd done
my job decently,
nobody knew who I was.
But the people I'd met in
my life, everybody knew.
So we actually decided to try
to tell the story by letting
other people tell it.
So I went on my little
tour of asking friends
that we'd never
had this discussion
about if they would
talk to a reporter
from "The New York Times."
So Bill Russell, Steve
Nash, people like that who--
David Stern-- people
who then told my story.
And it was an amazing blessing
to have a come-together that
way, and have it--
it was prophetic, whatever
Dan said at that dinner table
that night, because it's
exactly the way it played out.
SACHIT EGAN: That's beautiful.
Thanks for sharing that.
We can talk about the fact that
the LGBTQ+ movement has made
incredible strides
over the past years.
The fact that we're having
this conversation today
may not have happened 10
years ago, which is wonderful.
But I remember-- so
I'm a big Kevin Garnett
fan, so I was a
fan of the Celtics
when Jason Collins became the
first openly out player in any
of the four major North
American professional sports.
And I remember
thinking, this is going
to be a big moment that-- this
is going to change sports.
This is a huge step.
And I feel like, in sports,
it hasn't taken off the way
that some of us had expected.
Wondering if you have any
thoughts about why that is,
or what sports can do
better to support people
in that situation.
JENNIFER AZZI: I
think continuing
to have people that speak
out, and are truthful, and are
willing to be open
and live their lives,
because everyone needs
role models that somehow
look a little like them, or
there's some commonality there.
And so I think,
even seeing Jason
was a wonderful thing for me.
And I just think we need more
people to be open and honest.
I think that's probably
the biggest thing.
Because there is
a lot of support,
but there's still so
much pressure and fear.
And you've grown up with that,
and you've grown up with--
I remember, as a kid,
feeling very conflicted.
I have a strong spiritual
belief and religion,
and so I felt very conflicted.
So do I choose this
core part of myself,
or do I feel this
pressure that I can't?
One thing my mom actually said
to me when I was a kid is--
when I came out to
her, I was like, well,
is God still going to love me?
And she said, well,
is there anything
that you could do to make
me love you any less?
And I was like, hm,
no, I guess not.
And she said, well,
that's God's love for you.
So you go out, and you be
an example for other people.
And I'm lucky that I
have that foundation,
but a lot of people don't.
And I think that's why
seeing Rick's strength,
and other people,
motivates me, and I
hope that we can do
the same for others.
RICK WELTS: I'm disappointed
that the progress hasn't
happened faster.
I separate a little
bit from the team side
from the rest of
the organization
because I think we have
made really good strides
in our business organizations
and in our league.
We are league leadership.
That, we talked about it.
We were talking about
Adam Silver earlier.
I've written in the pride parade
with Adam Silver in New York
City.
That's a pretty
cool commissioner.
And in our business
organizations,
I think all of our teams
now have diversity inclusion
councils.
I think there are very
powerful voices there.
And I think we have
tried to send out
every signal that this is going
to be an inclusive environment.
Yet on the playing side,
that's been harder.
So we had decided to
put the All-Star Game
in Charlotte, North
Carolina, a couple years ago.
Three years ago, I think.
And then the legislature had
passed some very offensive
legislation to LGBTQ community.
And our league had to
decide whether or not
we were still going.
And Adam, in a owners'
meeting in Las Vegas,
gave me the last opportunity
to speak to the subject
before the owners voted on it.
And I just was able
to say honestly
to the owners sitting
around the room,
I'm in touch with people in a
lot of the organizations who
reach out and talk to me
because, for whatever reason,
they feel like they can
connect with somebody who's
in their situation,
and they don't feel yet
like they're in a
situation that they're
ready to take that step.
And I just want you to
think about those people
in your organizations
when you're
deciding what to do here.
And they voted not to
take the game there.
Now, things happened
subsequently
to improve the situation.
We are going back
there this year.
But I do think, for players,
you really have to remember.
I have to remind myself how
young these players are,
and what a short time they have
to earn a living at the one
thing they're always going
to be the best at doing.
And it's a huge
amount of pressure.
We're talking about
20-somethings.
I wasn't ready at
that point in time.
And yet we expect professional
athletes to have this maturity
beyond their years.
And so I still think
a lot of players
would look at it as a big risk.
I will tell you the
most interesting comment
I got through this whole process
was with a radio talk show
host in San Francisco who,
we were talking about this,
and he was a former player.
And he said, you
know, I don't think
there'd be an issue about
players accepting a gay player.
He says, I think
a player would be
very concerned about the
attention that would go along
with it, and the potential to
disrupt that very fragile team
environment, and
overwhelming to the team,
not just to the person.
And I think there's
something to that.
I think it's a very
fragile chemistry
that a team has to
have to be successful,
and things can disrupt that.
And I think players--
I think a lot of very
thoughtful players
have decided that, I'm not
sure I want to risk that
on behalf of my team.
Not because of how
it would affect me,
but on behalf of my team.
SACHIT EGAN: Very
interesting insight.
Thank you both
for sharing those.
Not to play a blame
game, but I think--
Jennifer, your answer
about what can we
do to improve the way things
are, you focused on leaders.
So if we have role
models and leaders
who create that culture,
things will move forward.
And you've mentioned
that the leaders are
trying to create that culture.
Players even seem
to be open to it.
So is it the media, then, that
we can blame a little bit?
Is there a way to
mitigate the response, or?
RICK WELTS: You know, it's
such a personal journey.
It's such a personal decision.
I could never
counsel anybody to--
[INAUDIBLE] you
have to [INAUDIBLE],,
or you need to do that.
I think it's a really--
it's going to happen.
I think it's likely to
happen with a young player,
maybe in college, who
comes into the pros who
has a different view of
the world than somebody
who's older.
But I really do understand it.
I'm disappointed in it,
but I understand it.
I will also add one thing.
My partner and I got invited to
the White House the last year
of Obama's presidency for
his pride celebration.
And his words come back
to me all the time,
because he was very proud of
what had been accomplished
during his administration.
And we're sitting in some
room at the White House,
and he's talking.
And he was giving the
most cautionary speech
that I thought was
even odd at the time.
It's like, this isn't over.
This could all get reversed
as quickly as it's happened.
And that weekend, the Pulse
nightclub shooting happened.
And I think, culturally,
in this country,
we've taken a couple steps back.
And I think some things
maybe are at risk today
that maybe, five years
ago, we would have assumed
were forever.
And so I think there's also--
the environment's
changed a little bit,
I think, in our culture.
I think hate is a
real thing today,
more so than it was five
years ago, in part of,
we've empowered
people to express it
in ways that maybe were
unthinkable-- at least to me--
five years ago.
And I think there's a little
of that environment that's
probably playing
into it as well.
SACHIT EGAN: That's also
a fantastic insight.
Thanks for sharing
that story with us.
I think, to shift gears
just a little bit,
talking about identity, there's
all sorts of different things
that go into identity.
There's all different
kinds of diversity.
In talking with you,
Jennifer, all the work
you're doing with the Azzi
Academy, and your role
with the NBA now, you're
really reaching out
to bring basketball and
bring a future in basketball
to the masses, all types
of different folks.
Can you tell us a little
bit about the work
that you're doing?
JENNIFER AZZI: Sure.
And just to give you
a little background.
The NBA brand, globally--
and I think Rick can probably
speak to this more
as well, but if you
look at what they're doing
for youth around the world,
if you look at it
like a pyramid,
there's Junior NBA,
which is worldwide now.
Then there are
basketball schools.
Then there are academies,
and then there's
global academies at
the top of the pyramid.
And that's where we're
working currently, as my wife
and I actually get
to work together
on this, which is really fun.
But we get to develop the
programming for the women
around the world, which
is really exciting.
So to go somewhere like
India, I wasn't sure
what they would be able to
do, what the talent's like.
And every region
that we've been in,
so whether it's Latin
America, India, China,
Senegal, the thing that
I've taken away from it
is, number one, basketball
is a universal language.
So even if the kids don't
speak English and have
a hard time with it,
you can put anyone
on the court from any walk of
life, any background, any race,
and you can play
this beautiful game.
And so that's exciting.
But the players that
we've been working with
are so grateful, so
it's so wonderful
to go around and have kids
say, in India, thank you
for coaching us.
I was like, what?
Are you sure?
But they're just
so, so respectful.
And I love that you know the
NBA is so respectful of women,
and is also investing
not just in the men's
academies around the world,
but also in developing
women around the world.
And on the men's side,
it's pretty clear.
The goal is, if you can
have a residential program--
which is a little bit like
being in college here,
but without quite the
academic pressures,
and you can practice
all the time,
so you don't have
the NCAA rules.
But if they can use the NBA
technology to develop a player
out of India or China,
you think about the impact
Yao Ming had here, and also
had on the market in China.
That's huge for the
global brand of the NBA.
But again, I'm happy
that they're also
investing in the women's side.
SACHIT EGAN: Here's
an interesting one
that we've gotten from
our global audience,
that we all feel lucky
to work for Google.
"I don't know a
Googler that hasn't
experience some form of failure
in the course of their career.
Can you share a moment in
which you failed on your path
to where you are now,
and how that shaped you?"
RICK WELTS: [CHUCKLES]
JENNIFER AZZI: I probably have--
no, I have more than Rick.
RICK WELTS: No,
you don't have any.
JENNIFER AZZI: I have
a couple few good ones,
but I'll keep it short.
I'm just going to go
back to my experience
at the University
of San Francisco.
When I took over,
I really thought
that we could win faster,
just because I thought,
we can work harder, and.
We won four games my first
year and five my second year.
And that was really,
really, really hard.
And then also being a coach,
not a player, you're sort of one
removed from-- you
can't go out and do it.
So that was really challenging.
And at the time, I don't know
that I looked at it as failure.
I think everyone
around me did, though,
because I had done
nothing but win.
So I remember my college
coach, don't take this job.
My dad called me on a
regular basis, are you OK?
It's like everyone
just looked at, here
I am, just treading
water, failing.
And there was
something inside of me
that knew that we were going
to eventually-- we couldn't
look at our wins and losses.
We had to look at
our incremental steps
towards getting better.
But that was very,
very difficult.
And I'm sure as
much as people say
it's got to be heaven working
at Google, coming on the campus,
you can go out and
play whatever you want.
It's pretty cool.
You can eat.
You can do everything.
Probably bring your
dogs, kids, right?
SACHIT EGAN: Oh, yeah.
JENNIFER AZZI: But I'm
sure there are also
the challenges that
come with any job,
and I think you just
have to stay true
to whatever your vision
is, and why you're there
in the first place.
SACHIT EGAN: Cool.
Thank you.
We'll take an audience question.
AUDIENCE: For both of you.
You mentioned at the beginning
that your organization
was changing and other
voices were coming out.
When you have so
many superstars,
but you also have
hidden superstars,
how are you able to--
because all those ideas,
each one could
actually be a success.
But when you have all the ideas
together-- and my main question
is, how do you bring
the hidden ideas
from those people who are
less willing to speak up,
less willing to share.
Maybe they're not bringing
their whole self yet,
but they have an
amazing idea, and that's
why they were hired here.
JENNIFER AZZI: Interesting.
AUDIENCE: How are you
bringing that out?
RICK WELTS: Well, I love
our coach, Steve Kerr.
And actually, he coined
a phrase a few years ago
that we've adopted
organizationally
as our mantra, not only
our basketball team,
and that's strength in numbers.
And what's behind
strength in numbers
is that, yeah, we got Steph
Curry and Kevin Durant.
But without the other
12 guys on the roster,
we're not going to
win a championship.
And they've created
an atmosphere
in the locker room
that celebrates
the individual craziness
of each one of those guys.
It's the funniest locker room
in the history of the world.
Everybody gets made fun
of, whether you're the best
player or the worst player.
And there's something
about who you
are that everybody decides
is the most fun thing to make
fun of the whole time.
And it's different in
our business environment.
We do, actually, a lot of
training and coaching on this,
on meeting dynamics
and things like that,
because there's some wonderful
science around it now.
The people who really care about
getting the best out of people
really can understand that
there isn't a one-size-fits-all,
outgoing, hard-charging
personality that can dominate
a room in the meeting and
you get the best result.
It doesn't always work that way.
And I think it's
a work in progress
for us to make sure
that the voices--
that we're extracting the
best out of each of the people
we have by making them feel
like they not only have
the opportunity, but the
obligation to contribute
their thoughts if they're
in an environment where
an issue's being discussed.
The way I see it,
you're in this meeting
because you're a smart person
who has a point of view,
and I expect you
to express that.
It's harder for some people
than it is for others,
and a lot of guys forget to
listen to a lot of other people
sometimes when there's
talking in a meeting.
And we try to call
people out on that.
We try to actually
get better at that.
And I do think it's a process.
I don't think we're there
yet, but I think the fact
that we're aware of it,
and want to make sure
that we're providing
that platform for people
to be the best they can be is
something that we stand for.
JENNIFER AZZI: I just
have a quick little story.
So when I was also coaching at
USF, we lost to Santa Clara.
And it was when we
were getting better,
and we literally should
have just crushed them.
And so I could feel that we had
some issues and things going on
with the team.
So I said, all
right, guys, we're
going to all get in a room,
and we're going to talk.
And I want you guys
to say anything
to me that you
might need to say,
get off your chest, whatever.
We've got to figure out
whatever's going on.
So we get in the room,
and one of the players who
doesn't speak a lot
said, well, coach, I just
don't know if we
should have a stopwatch
and times on our sprints
because some players are having
a hard time, and they're
really struggling
with making the times.
And I'm thinking, oh my God,
I have to listen to the ideas
that I think are crazy too.
I'm asking for this.
But to provide an
environment where I actually
could get stuff back that
I didn't want to hear,
and that I thought
might be ridiculous.
But what it did is it helped me
to get to the psychology of why
those kids were upset.
And I explained to the group.
I'm like, a basketball
game is 40 minutes.
It doesn't change unless,
obviously, you go to overtime
or whatever.
So we have to have
a time and a score,
and we have to have
measurements on what we do.
Now, the ones that are really
struggling with this, maybe
let's figure out
how you can either
eat better, work on
some other areas,
and work on the mental side so
you don't feel so much pressure
in making your times.
Because I'm not getting mad
at them for not making them.
It's just, this is the standard.
But it was just really
interesting to get
in a room with them and
listen to some things
that I think they were
just scared to say.
And again, I think
as a leader, you
have to be OK with
the things that you
don't agree with,
and maybe figure out
why they're thinking
and feeling that way
so they feel validated.
AUDIENCE: So winning
solves a lot of problems,
especially in sports.
But right now, the
Warriors are going
through a bit of a tough time,
at least for Warrior standards.
RICK WELTS: Won three in a row!
AUDIENCE: I know.
You lost to my
Bucks by 35, though.
JENNIFER AZZI: Uh-oh.
RICK WELTS: Crushed.
AUDIENCE: So how are you
managing the conflict that's
going on right now
with the organization,
both in terms of win
and losses, but also
with what's going
on in the media
with the story about
Draymond and KD, for example?
RICK WELTS: Did I
mention I love our coach?
Yeah.
I love our coach.
He's the best.
He has a way of diffusing any
situation and making it OK.
And he's a master at it.
I try to learn from him, because
the idea that two players have
a argument on the
basketball court
is not like the first
time that's ever happened.
We happen to have
a microscope on us,
unlike any other team in the
NBA, maybe in sports right now.
And we have 29 other
teams and media
rooting for a
storyline that shows
that the cracks in the
armor finally appearing,
and this whole thing's
ready to fall apart.
So it's bring the group together
and have an honest discussion
about what's going on, what
people are going to ask,
what our responses as
teammates ought to be.
And I think that that ship
got righted pretty quickly.
Couldn't agree with you more.
We have an industry-- the
biggest fault in our industry
is that we've designed an
industry where half the teams
have to lose every night.
I don't know if you
focused on that.
When you work at Google, you
win most of the time, right?
If you work in sports,
half the teams--
you're pretty much certain--
are going to lose every night.
So you can't just
build it on winning,
because law of
averages, it's not
going to continue to
be that way forever.
We've had an amazing streak.
It's a historic streak.
We're trying to go to the finals
for the fifth consecutive year.
And I don't know how many
basketball historians who are
there, it's been done before.
I don't know if you can
name who has done it.
Maybe Magic Johnson's Lakers?
No.
Maybe--
SACHIT EGAN: Russell's Celtics?
RICK WELTS: --Rayburn's Celtics?
No.
Maybe Michael Jordan's Bulls?
Hasn't been done since Bill
Russell's Celtics in the '60s.
So it's historic, what
we're trying to do now.
And the pressure
mounts as time goes on.
Sounds like it should
make it easier.
In some ways, it
makes it harder.
And I think that you have to
have a leader in the locker
room, not only as your
coach, but as a player who's
willing to add perspective.
We have some great ones.
Andre Iguodala is
Mr. Perspective.
Steph Curry doesn't talk
a lot, but when he speaks,
everybody listens.
Draymond Green has his role.
You know?
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
RICK WELTS: But he's the
only one who plays that role.
We need that on our team.
So I think it's
just a willingness
to engage as teammates,
and a willingness
to decide as
teammates how you want
to respond to these things.
And having a leader
in your coach
that's willing to make
that forum happen,
and force that
conversation to take place.
SACHIT EGAN: Cool.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Well, thanks a lot
just for your time.
It's been really great just
to hear your different stories
and your experiences.
I was really relating a lot,
because I've also played sports
as well, and sports has been
a big part of my life too.
And I've been a part of
big teams on the court
as well as off the
court and professions,
and I remember different times
where I've been in a situation
where you're trying
to change the culture,
and I was relating a lot to
what you were saying with,
you have the vision of what
you're trying to achieve,
and you're trying to bring
everybody along there.
And some people might get
it, some people may not.
But one thing I have
experienced too, or have seen,
is that when leaders are in
that situation, or in those--
the times right before
it starts to turn,
that you can feel alone,
and like your vision,
and like what
you're trying to do,
and you might even wonder to
yourself, is this really right?
Or maybe self-doubt,
or things like that.
So just curious, have you
experienced that, or just
different thoughts
along those lines?
JENNIFER AZZI: Yeah.
You described that really well.
And I think, too, it's
the classic thing in life
too, right?
Right when something's
about to turn,
you're almost ready
to quit, but you
know there's something
telling you to stick with it,
stick with it, stick with it.
But there are many times,
before I walk into the gym,
feeling like, am I the only
one that really believes this?
Am I the only one
that sees this?
We had a moment with our team
before we won the championship.
We were huddled up at center
court, which we would do that
after every practice.
And I had just found
out, regardless
of how we performed
in the WCC tournament,
that we would go to the NIT.
Which, for USF at that
time, going to the NIT
is still a really big--
that's a successful season.
You're at 20 wins.
It's a big deal.
We were rated sixth going into
the conference tournament.
But sixth in our
conference was literally
a matter of one or two points.
You could have been in second.
It just was that tight.
So we had to upset three,
two, and one to end up
winning the whole thing.
So I didn't want them
to feel any pressure.
I was like, you guys
have had a great season.
We're on our way.
Go have fun.
We're holding hands.
One of the players--
and I'm not going to say
what she said exactly,
but she said, coach-- it
was like she was mad at me.
She said, coach, "mm" the NIT.
We're going to the
NCAA tournament.
And I still have chills
when I think about it,
because it shifted from
my feeling it to them.
It shifted from me to them.
So when we went to that
tournament, I just knew.
I was like, they got it.
This is not me
walking to the gym
by myself saying the same
thing over and over again.
And so I did.
It felt like a shift from me to
us all really coming together.
We needed that in order to
do what we did that season.
So great point, because I don't
know that people necessarily
articulate that that well.
RICK WELTS: I think everybody
has exact those feelings.
If you're going to try to
do things that are hard,
and do things that maybe
haven't been done before,
you're going to feel like
you're out there on an island
once in a while.
Everybody does.
And I was having
this conversation--
did I tell you I love our coach?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
RICK WELTS: I was having
this conversation with him
not that long ago,
and we're kind
of going back to the beginning.
He had never coached a game
before he coached the Golden
State Warriors.
He'd won five championships,
but he'd never been a coach.
And he was talking
about exactly that.
All the preparation that went
into his first training camp,
and sitting there at his
first game going like,
I have no idea if any of
this is going to work.
And he had that moment.
He had that moment where
it's like, I don't know.
I've done everything
I think I can do,
but I don't know if
this is going to work.
So you shouldn't feel--
it's almost comforting
to know that everybody
has those moments.
And you have to push
your way through
and get to the other side.
AUDIENCE: Hi, yes.
Thanks for being here.
This has been really great.
And thank you for
sharing your stories.
I wanted to touch on
something that we talked
about earlier around
bringing your whole self,
and this concept
of vulnerability,
and with athletes who,
in order to become
an elite athlete, the
amount of self-belief
that you have to have in
yourself to get there,
but also creating
a culture where
it's safe to be accepting
of what you may not possess,
or your faults, or
your vulnerabilities.
So in an environment
just like that,
how you navigate those
types of situations.
RICK WELTS: You're the athlete.
SACHIT EGAN: [CHUCKLING]
JENNIFER AZZI: I guess if
I look at it from being
the athlete in the locker
room, not the coach,
I think you're right.
It's like, athletes have that--
if you're at a
certain level, you've
got that confidence,
and that belief,
and that strength, and that--
so how do you show
that other side?
I do think, to Rick's point
earlier, it's really difficult.
Even in a women's locker
room, it's very difficult,
because you're supposed to
be strong and keep people
together.
But I think, if you
have good leadership,
be it in coaching, or
captains, or people--
I also love Steve Kerr.
He's amazing.
I think he does such a
fantastic job with this.
But I think just encouraging
people to be themselves.
Because I think
if anyone has been
in any sort of
successful situation,
you know that the group
does better when people
are authentically themselves.
Even that strong dude
in the locker room.
It's important that people
can be vulnerable and share
all sides.
There still has to be a
professionalism, though.
Because it doesn't
mean that everyone's
going to go out and hang out,
and it's all friendly friendly,
but there has to be some
level of being who you are.
RICK WELTS: I think
it's a great question.
I think one of the biggest
challenges in business
is getting people
to ask questions
about things they
don't understand,
especially like in a meeting
environment or something.
I try to be that guy
in the meeting who--
like, I know nobody understood
what that person just said,
but everyone's afraid to
look like the dumb one who
didn't get it.
So I like to be that one.
I like to be that dumb one.
Like, I have no idea
what you just said.
I have no idea what that means.
Can you explain to
me what that means?
And it can take the
pressure out of a group.
And as a leader, I
think you can influence
how much more
confident people are
in being inquisitive about
things that they feel
vulnerable about, because
you're prepared to make yourself
vulnerable too.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
coming here today and sharing
your thoughts and feelings.
So my question's
a bit about ego.
In sports, you definitely
see ego play out
in terms of players not
being willing to sacrifice
their roles.
And it's common today in the NBA
to have these three-star teams.
The Miami Heat, the Warriors.
And I like to think
about the times
where you saw Jordan make
that extra pass to one
of the shooters,
or LeBron learn how
to trust Mario
Chalmers, or Bosh.
Or even on the flip side,
how Bosh had to accept,
OK, I'm not going to be
the first option anymore.
Can you talk to me about
how you talk to your players
about relinquishing that ego,
that ability, or the thought
process, like, I'm
the man, or the woman,
and I'm going to score 25
a night, as opposed to,
I'm going to sacrifice
so that we can win.
JENNIFER AZZI: Well,
I think you just
have to ask people if
they want to win or not.
If you want to win, this is
what we need to do to get there.
I think the Warriors,
this season,
great example when Klay Thompson
ended up breaking Steph Curry's
3-point record,
and Steph's the one
making sure he has the ball.
It's like, I think Steph is
the ultimate team player.
And as good as he is, I
think that's contagious.
And I think, when you
have that on a team,
that you can be
really successful.
And I think, if winning
is the priority over self,
obviously, then I think
you can get there.
But I think leadership matters.
I think having a coach
like Steve, really,
he's able to manage all those
different personalities,
and make them all feel
included and important
regardless to the
points on the board.
RICK WELTS: I think
for our team, the thing
that our general manager
Bob Myers always points to
was when we asked Andre
Iguodala, NBA All-Star,
Olympic champion, to not
start, and to come off
the bench, which, for an NBA
player, is a big difference.
And he willingly
accepted that role.
And as an example
to his team, it
was extraordinary,
and really helped
set the tone for the
team that we have today,
because he was willing to accept
something that a lot of players
wouldn't have been
willing to accept.
SACHIT EGAN: Very cool.
And I think, unless, there's
any more audience questions,
we'll ask one more.
I think when you
look at the Warriors
as they're currently
built, and as they've
been built through
this run, there
are so many players who fit
a certain mold really well.
Even the guys like Livingston
at one time, Mo Speights.
Everybody plays that role well.
And you always talk about
Steve Kerr, and the way
that he commands
people's respect.
I don't think I knew how good he
was at that until he took over
as coach of the Warriors.
Observing him, is there
a trait or set of traits
that he utilizes to
get that respect?
RICK WELTS: He's an
awesome communicator,
and there's no
player on his roster
who's confused about
what the role is,
or what they should be doing,
or what his expectations are
for them.
And as easy as that sounds,
I think a lot of coaches
aren't really good at that,
and players are not sure
exactly where they fit.
And I will say that one
of the benefits of having
some sustained success is, all
those players aren't the same.
You mentioned DeMarcus Cousins,
or Matt Barnes, or Nick Young,
or players that, in
other environments,
may not have
succeeded really well.
Because of the structure
of that team now,
and the leadership
in the locker room,
you can bring a player
like that in who
can have a new approach to the
way they're playing the game.
I remember-- God, I
sound really old now--
Dennis Johnson.
Is that a player you ever--
Hall of Fame player.
We drafted him at the
Sonics when I was there.
Incredibly athletic.
Could jump out of the gym.
Couldn't hit the side
of the barn shooting
when he was drafted.
And won a championship
with us as a starting two
guard with the Sonics.
Was a total jerk the
whole time he was there.
Was not a good teammate.
Was not a good
person to be around.
Got traded to Phoenix.
Had the same problem in
Phoenix after a couple years.
Got traded to Boston and became
a completely different player,
because he got put in an
environment with Larry Bird,
Robert Parrish, Kevin McHale.
And that wasn't the
way it worked there.
And he wasn't the big dog there.
And he became the best
player imaginable, All-Star
repeatedly, champion repeatedly.
But if you can create
the right culture,
you can bring people into that
culture who may not naturally
gravitate toward that, but
will because of the strength
of the people around them.
SACHIT EGAN: Very cool.
Jennifer and Rick,
thanks for being here.
Thanks for your time.
Appreciate it.
JENNIFER AZZI: Thank you.
RICK WELTS: Thank you.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
JENNIFER AZZI: Thank you.
RICK WELTS: It was a lot of fun.
Yeah, thank you.